We are here with the beautiful Heather Locklear,
who I've known most of my life.
We played the mother and daughter when I was seven and she
was 21 in Firestarter, and you have this new project called
Don't Sweat the Small Stuff: The Kristine Carlson story,
and I would love for you to talk about this project and the
history of the writer and his wife that you are playing
who becomes the hero of the story.
Right. Well, I think in the nineties, the Don't Sweat
the Small Stuff came out and it sold like 20 million copies,
I don't know, a bunch of copies,
and this Kris who I play and her husband, Richard,
were very spiritual people, honestly, on a different level.
And they were such a unique couple together and they would
meditate every morning together in bed,
have their coffee, and had two girls,
And they had started writing books together,
but she was doing the mom thing and he was doing his work.
Anyway, so he passes away and suddenly,
and suddenly Kris has to become him,
him and her, mother and a father,
keeping the brand together,
going through such a grieving process that she learned,
like, this is the big stuff, don't sweat the small stuff,
let's like, live moment to moment and enjoy every moment.
And that will, might help take care of the big stuff,
but at least when the big stuff comes,
you'll feel confident that you will get through it,
and she's such a, like an angel, honestly,
and she's just full of wisdom, full of spirituality.
And there were so many synchronicities between the two of us
and between her and her husband.
And, anyway,
with her two daughters,
the strength that she had to raise those two,
to keep it together, to keep the brand going,
and she is still today.
And so with her, her book, this book,
it's such a journey through what she went to through when
she heard he passed, and until, you know,
a couple of years after of her life and how she had to
accept and move forward.
You can either sit back and feel bad, or you have to,
you have to move forward and that will get you out.
So she's just an amazing human being.
And it's really the story of these three girls, women,
women, two girls,
and how they stick together and get through this tragic
thing that- he was only 45 years old when he died.
And then she found, like letters.
She had all these love letters of his.
She, well, first when she came back,
all of, there was things in the house that he had written
down like, don't forget the dog medicine,
don't forget that this don't forget
this is what happens on Wednesday and Thursday.
Like he had known somehow that he was slowing down,
I don't know. So these were, she'd find them in books,
but then he had written on her,
on their 18th wedding anniversary,
he gave her this like semi book.
And so she's looking at this and he's like,
if I had my life to live over again,
I wouldn't change a thing, Kris, you are the loved one.
It was almost like a goodbye.
And he passed three years later.
And so, you know,
and this is also a book, it's One Hour to Live, One Hour to
Love.
Yeah.
And so it was, it's also incredible, you know,
for anyone who's going through loss or divorce or pet going
or losing your job, it's pretty amazing.
I appreciate people who go out there and say:
love, it's okay.
Live as if you have no fears or there may not be a luxury of
time.
These are profound things to me, and I parent that way too,
I parent very lovingly.
You are so right. My daughter, I would,
I used to be afraid of saying goodbye and hugging people,
and my girlfriend would say, why don't you hug me?
So then I hug everyone,
the guy who was taking out my groceries,
that they don't do that anymore, but I'd hug him.
I'm sowing, okay,
I gotta get over this, you know, shyness.
And my daughter says
I love you when she hangs up to anyone, I love you.
When you're going, when she leaves, she loves, like,
I think, you know,
she's afraid that if she doesn't say that,
you know, how guilty she would feel if something happened to
anyone, but she taught me that.
And so I love you Drew, so much.
I love you too. I do.
(clapping)
And I was so excited to see you today and reconnect,
and speaking of reconnecting and love,
may I ask you about reconnecting with your high school
sweetheart?
No! No, I'm kidding.
Of course you can, yeah.
You met this man in high school.
So I suppose he was a young man or a boy at that.
He was 15.
First of all, when you guys were making out,
could anyone tell you apart.
(laughter)
Are you kidding, no.
Here's the thing he was, he's better looking.
He's cuter than me. I'm like, oh.
And then my thought is, I'm like, no,
I don't think they knew heads or tails.
You look like two halves that make the perfect whole here
or go to the same hair stylist, it's perfect.
I didn't realize he actually did his hair,
but he obviously did his hair, He didn't say it
didn't just go like that.
He worked as hard as on his hair as I worked on mine,
just saying.
Exactly, I love it.
I love it. It's so meant to be.
And then you reconnected years later.
40 Years later, is there 40 older than you?
40 years later.
No, I'm 36.
Having been a mother-daughter with you,
I'm so excited for this new film to come out.
I think the whole subject is really going to speak to people
and I have loved cheering you on since I was seven,
I will continue to do so for my entire life
Vice versa
Thank you for all the good,
amazing things that you have brought into this world.
Thank you. And vice versa.
(cheering)
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Heather's new movie Don't Sweat the Small Stuff:
The Kristine Carlson Story premieres tomorrow on Lifetime.
(cheerful music)